hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 18 video
the frenemy of my enemy this week was
all about shifting alliances so I'm
expecting you know versions of this to
happen in Captain America Civil War this
episode took that to the logical next
step you know alliances changing many
many many times you could also consider
it a minor crossover with age of Ultron
but but but only because of a passing
comment in one of those Hydra scenes so
just careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet I'll
actually start with that the only real
point of crossover in the episode was
when they referred to Baron von Strucker
and dr. list being obsessed like crazy
obsessed with powered people as we know
Baron von Strucker using Loki's staff to
experiment on people to try to try and
create powered people slightly different
from what's going on with the Inhumans
but Coulson and his team members don't
know anything about that
based on the Winter Soldier post-credit
scene I'd even go as far to say that von
Strucker is keeping his experiments
secret from the rest of all of Hydra so
even though dr. lists found a way to
track Gordon to track the teleporter he
still probably has no idea what Baron
von Strucker is doing with Quicksilver
and Scarlet Witch so here we go top five
WTF moments starting with number five
Fitz shakes the tail and joins team
Coulson I think we all expected this
after the last episode so it wasn't a
huge surprise but it was nice to see
Fitz go on the run you know be a little
bit of a secret agent we don't get a lot
of opportunities to see James Bond Fitz
the next step up would be like parkour
Fitz the real action from his character
was in dealing with the alliance that
they had to make with Ward the the
person who caused him to have all those
mental problems that's only gonna get
worse now - because Coulson turned
himself in I supposed to infiltrate the
real shield so Fitz is left with hunter
Ward in agent 33 so he's probably even
less happy than he was before
on to number four Coulson makes a deal
with war to get intel on Hydra if it was
a little confusing as to why he needed
to make the deal with Ward it's because
he needed information on the Inhumans
from Hydra the only war could get so
that he could find where Gordon took
Skye that Mexican restaurant that they
had their scene in that's one of my
favorite agents of shield sets in recent
memory it's just so funny how they meet
in like the most mundane places like
they might go to some other hole in the
wall eventually and have some shwarma
over some really tense meeting didn't
you think it was interesting
the deathlok asked agent 33 if she had a
spare mask lying around as much as he's
full-on
Deathlok now he still thinks about his
appearance like he still wants to look
more human then we have the big tahini
call-out that was a lot of fun
so what Coulson was talking about the
Tahiti protocol is just the Mindwipe
nothing else when he said Tahiti though
you know your mind kind of goes to Crede
blood it's like are they gonna kill him
does he have to die and they're gonna
resurrect him no really it's just what
they did to Coulson after they
resurrected him when he had that giant
machine poking around in his open skull
that does not look like fun so you can't
fault ward for being a little
apprehensive
Coulson does try to appeal to the
humanity in him but they're both kind of
playing each other
Coulson's like I give you my word as the
director of shield but you know surprise
surprise he's not the director of shield
anymore and Ward is probably lying
through his teeth too that just goes
back to the frenemy of my enemy line
they both know they can't trust each
other but they have a bigger common
enemy so they're working together
temporarily that's why I think that Ward
was so willing to help Coulson in that
big firefight at the end and he has a
bigger goal that he's trying to achieve
anyway so it's in his best interest to
keep Coulson alive it does make you
wonder if there's gonna be some sort of
redemption for his character at a
certain point really I don't care I
think he's a lot of fun the way he is
right now being totally bad the whole
potted plant house of agent 33 was a
little surreal so you know we will see
what that ends up looking like they
might have some twisted romance think
Joker Harley Quinn kind of thing onto
number three Skye goes on a
daddy-daughter date with her father I
think we all knew he was gonna lose his
mind at a certain point we were just
kind of waiting for the Hat to drop was
it gonna be the thugs that bumped her in
the street was it gonna be the Hydra
agents I thought the minute he saw that
the pastry shop had been replaced with a
bank that was gonna be it once he found
out what was really going on like what
the Inhumans plan really was like to
dump him off he's he get pissed but he
still wanted to save Skye
he jumped in the portal with Gordon and
Skye so I'll be interested to see you
know what they do how that changes the
dynamic back at the Inhumans base back
at the afterlife you know whatever they
want to call it because they're gonna
want to rescue Lincoln the whole site
trip is also a nice callback to the
comics Daisy Johnson is the quake
character that's that's who Skye is
basically the comic book character so
she just she says her name out loud just
to hear what it sounds like she found
out that her first name was really Daisy
and now she found out what the last name
was what I'd like to
see it in like a future season whenever
dies down she's forced to go
undercover and just just as like a point
of comedy she uses the secret name Daisy
Johnson technically Daisy Johnson
doesn't exist in the real world there's
no birth certificate or anything like
that so she could use it as an alias on
to number two
Coulson and ward used Bakshi to
infiltrate Hydra this is gonna be the
real test seeing whether or not his
conditioning holds up that the end of
the episode made it seem like he turned
on them again like he'd broken his
programming agents of shield is all
about shocking twist so I wouldn't be
surprised if he really is still
conditioned and this is all an act like
he's just acting for Hydra for the
benefit of Hydra that was really awesome
evil grin on his face though did anybody
else see the Star Wars Easter Egg
whenever they were on the airplane and
he's like I offer you death lock wait
they're giving him to him it's like when
Luke Skywalker offered c-3po and r2d2 to
Jabba in his palace just just to
ingratiate himself to them since they
captured death lock and Lincoln at the
end of the episode I'll be answered to
see if they really do try to upgrade his
compliance software there's really only
about four episodes left so they'll be
like a couple more shocking twists and
I'm still expecting like a really crazy
big villain reveal like you know
Whitehall to step out of the shadows or
something even bigger that we haven't
seen yet something unexpected if I like
my number one WTF moment Closen doubles
back and turns himself into the real
shield so if this seems confusing just
remember the title of the episode the
frenemy of my enemy so now I think you
know Coulson feels like real shield is a
less of an enemy than Hydra is so he's
gonna lie with them temporarily without
them knowing it I don't know that he
cares a whole lot about Lincoln like he
doesn't know a lot about him right now
but he'll probably try and save him too
because he's trying to save Deathlok he
is gonna get like the biggest slap in
the face from me though whenever he gets
back she saw him with Ward so she
probably thinks that he's turned it's
really hard to tell what's going on
inside her head I don't think that she's
completely turned on Coulson but it's a
very Captain America Civil War type
thing where it's like the truth matters
it's not about sides
I think Coulson turn himself in as a
measure of last resort though like they
need resources that real shield has
access to he needs to go back to the
base word was like we're out man out gun
we just we can't do it by ourselves we
need more help so either Coulson is
gonna try and turn more people inside
real shield to help him out or he's
gonna try and make a bargain with Roche
like he made with ward so they did a
really good job of tying all the
different running plots together
thematically with the title of the
episode here's my big question for you
guys though what do you think the
Coulson's gonna try and do to get
Deathlok back and what do you think the
Inhumans are gonna do to try and get
Lincoln back what I'm hoping happens is
that they all like all these different
forces converge on dr. lists on Hydra
right now he seems like the likely
candidate for Big Bad that is unless
Whitehall resurfaces which is totally
possible but right now dr. list is like
the biggest Hydra person that isn't
Bakshi this whole system of shifting
alliances is one of the reasons why I
think shield works so well this week it
does a really good job of telling these
types of stories that's why I think it
was able to crossover with Captain
America Winter Soldier in a much bigger
way and why I think that next year
whenever we get to Captain America Civil
War there will be like a much deeper
integration with agents of shield beyond
the minor points of crossover that I
already mentioned that there weren't a
whole lot of Easter eggs in the episode
there was a Hulk shot out but I don't
consider it much of an easter egg but if
you did see anything like really
specific any you know logos or anything
like that in the background let me know
just a reminder in related news I'm
working on more daredevil videos in an
arrow flash Q&A for this week so I'll
try to get that up by Saturday be sure
to subscribe to get everything
I'm also I'm gonna do like an Avengers
age of Ultron Q&A too but I'm gonna wait
till after I post my spoiler review next
week in case you guys haven't seen it I
actually just did a non-spoilery review
for age of Ultron you can click here to
watch it and you can click here for all
my other Marvel agents of shield videos
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you